how do you know that the director is the
real deal
i'm not especially big on on judging
people in an absolute way
so what i would characterize is is
is directors i am most fulfilled working
with and
and that would be interactive ones you
know
i i want somebody who both brings ideas
and has you know very strong
feelings but is also collaborative you
know
and is willing to if a better idea is
presented
you know whether it's the producer or
the actor or the craft services person
is open to considering that you know
because it's it's about
the movie we are all making not about
you know their ego
um so that's my that's my preferred
archetype
um uh the ones who aren't prepared
you know frustrate me because we should
all be prepared
um the ones who
you know when i say how would you like
to shoot this and they say what do you
think
a few times that's okay i mean i've
asked my
lighting crew before i'm a little
stymied do you have any ideas
but but if that is the standard mo
well i'm carrying them and it's it's not
fun
for me i mean maybe it would be fun for
somebody else maybe there's
you know a dp out there who just has
delusions of grandeur and as a wannabe
director who would be thrilled to work
with that person
but for me um it's a collaboration you
know i want to feel like we're
we're doing something together and if
i'm getting nothing from them then it's
kind of like
it's just not that much fun and same on
the other hand if i have somebody who
is really overbearing and controlling
and i feel like i have no
input then i just you know i don't
it's not fun it's not exciting it's kind
of like
i just feel like i'm um
you know just a i don't even know what
you'd call it just a
um a worker drone you know just
taking instructions and not not
interpreting at all
so you know again to me the sweet spot
is in the middle
and there's a range too i mean you know
it could be you know a little more me or
a little more of them i mean that's okay
you know it could tilt
and and you know with with good people
sometimes it does tilt you know
sometimes
you know like i said you know sometimes
you know somebody may say to me why
don't you take the lead on this one i'm
like okay let's do that
you know or sometimes they're like no i
know exactly how i want this
um so so you know that dynamic being
being flexible and throughout that's
okay but it's
it's really that when you get in that
default mode if it tilts too far
one way or the other and just every day
is like that then
you know it's that's not the thing that
gets me excited to get out of bed in the
morning
what is not being prepared
um well not having a sense of how you
want to cover a scene
not having a sense of of
the type of coverage you want not having
some sense of how you want to cut the
scene
and and i will qualify this by saying
it's perfectly okay to have that idea
and get on set and have an epiphany and
throw it all away and say let's do
something different
that's fine you know but at least we
have a fallback plan we are never going
to get to set and go
i i don't know what i want to do you
know and
then you know time
drags to a stop anytime that stuff
happens you know in my mind it's sand
going out of
my hourglass to do nice lighting you
know
somebody's eating up time if time is
being wasted
i'm gonna have to make up for it because
somebody's gonna say light it's simpler
light it quicker shoot it unless
you know less coverage um you know
that's that's where the
the the the buck is gonna stop and it's
it's depressing to me you know
in the same way that i don't want the
director waiting on me
to light a scene you know i want the
people to have that
already roughed in so that when we walk
in there it comes in and maybe just some
tweaks
in that same way i don't really want to
be sitting there
waiting on somebody else whether it's
the director or
wardrobe or the actor because you know
if we're i've worked with there's a
particular
music video artist i worked with who
just showed up six hours late
you know that's that's that person's
money
you know they paid for it they paid our
salaries but
you know it's like that's again that's
not why i'm there is to make that money
i mean i want
you know you show up and i show up i
don't want to show up at six a.m
you know but we do because we are
supposed to
and we get the thing done and and you
have the time as the director or the
actor to
to make your magic and i have the time
to make my magic
and and and that happens in being
prepared and not
you know waiting for being on set to get
that sorted out
how do you handle a director not liking
your suggestions
um well as a general thing i'm
ambivalent and i defer to them because
they're the director
you know if they never liked my
suggestions
i would feel we weren't a good match you
know
i mean i wouldn't hold it against them i
don't again i'm not going to judge them
just because their aesthetic is
different than mine
you know but we may have an incompatible
aesthetic
and that's just what my judgment would
be but but
yeah i mean if they were belligerent and
insulting and made it personal well that
would be weird i've never had that
happen
you know but for them to say no i don't
like that idea i'm not attached to it i
look we're all putting something in the
pot to make something amazing
like i said you know if if if the pa
comes up and gives me a lighting idea
and it's better than mine i'm gonna do
it
and i'll give them credit for it you
know it's it's you know all for one and
one for all i'm not an ego person
at all i'm not i'm i'm not that way and
i don't
particularly care to work with people
who are generally speaking
how much time does it take to light a
scene that
is a range between zero seconds
and infinity
okay i mean what's the scene are we
you know standing outside in a in a
close-up with beautiful
backlight and and a cliff face that's
bouncing light so it's perfect and i
just turn on the camera
or are we shooting a shot that starts
in um you know uh uh
you know the the the 101 freeway
and and somebody's walking down into
hollywood boulevard i mean well that
would probably be available lighting but
or or is it like a a steady cam shot
where we we walk into this house and we
walk through the back and we go into the
neighbor's yard and across the street
you know what i'm saying it's
you can't there's no generic answer it's
like it's like it could be simple it
could be complicated
you'd have to you'd have to give me a
specific scene and even inside of a
specific
scene i can say well here's how long it
would take if i wanted to do
a really good job and if we don't have a
lot of time here's an abbreviated
version
so in california christmas when we first
see
them sitting at the kitchen nook or the
breakfast table
and we're finding out different things
about the characters i don't want
spoilers i don't want to give too much
away but that there's an issue
and i think it's a daylight scene it
looks like it's more morning i think
they're making breakfast
how long did it take to light that scene
this beautiful light thank you
um 20 minutes maybe
um but uh i had it roughed in before we
got there you know
we didn't wait on it that was already
set up and we walked into it
ah okay so you're talking about 20
minutes once you
walked in no oh okay i took the guys
who went over there to do it 20 minutes
while we were shooting something else
and then we got there and while the
actors were getting set and the props
were getting set and the camera was
getting set
the lighting crew tweaked it and did not
infringe upon our time at all
ah okay but the sun went down
so then we had to put a silk over that
back window
i don't know if it was that scene but we
shot you know
we block shot a whole bunch of stuff
in there um i should i do we didn't
block you that's not that's not correct
we
we shot we would move the cameras around
between the scenes but
um but you know we shot all of the
scenes
in that space at the same time and
when the sun went down i had to cover
that front window
with diffusion so if you pay close
attention at a certain point you're
seeing detail out there and then it's
just white
and so that took a little bit of a reset
and we did have to wait on that because
we were in the middle
of that set but it wasn't long i mean it
took um
i don't know five five ten minutes to
reset that
but you know the barn took a long time
you know that barn we had them in there
pre i had a
we were on a shoot and i had we were on
a day and
and i was like okay let's shoot
exteriors so i can
spin the crew off and get them started
on that barn because it's going to take
a long time
so you know and also the bar the bar
took a while and that was i was nervous
because we did not have a pre-light
but we we did it so that we started
small we started on a small area of the
bar
and as we were shooting that behind us
they were finishing the lighting
but that's just another thing is like
you know you do not want to wait you
want you want to get up shooting as fast
as possible
you